hey reject nation how you do and we're
gonna watch the honest trailer today for
the greatest showmen a movie we both
really enjoyed can't we check this out
man
and hey patron of the day shout out for
Matthew the beer
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
that great
[Laughter]
whoa
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
ha
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that sounds cool we will learn more we
shall meet - I like women in general to
be quite honest there's a really good
honest trailer I love when the honest
trailers guys decide to write musical
parodies yeah I mean that was such a big
controversy behind this movie I need any
jack about PT Barnum before watching
this film all but you can bet that we
all learned a little sad yeah yeah I
learned a lot about how very inaccurate
the movie was yeah this is not a biopic
by any stretch they just took a basic
concept of a guy who started the circus
and had a freak show entertainment
that's all they took yeah the very
barest bones of PT Barnum story and made
him Hugh Jackman he had I mean granted
the film is a delightful movie Oh
filled with joy it's very distracting
when if you're like very well aware
though of all the real-life exploits and
how he wasn't really a good dude really
just to know how much they made up here
I think the part that really does have
set me with the movie something that did
feel as a missing element they don't
really hone in on the free show when
that's a big part of the appeal like
they own it on the show but they don't
have it on the characters yeah they
don't hone in on the performers and
actually less you know about their lives
and their experience should you get this
later jackass [ __ ] yeah yeah the focus
is all on you know these rich white dude
because I feel like even with the tone
and a kind of genre of film that they
were going for here you still could have
honed in a lot on characters the freaks
my favorite song is the one that brings
me to tears whenever I hear this is such
a great song that musical number touches
me the most and sometimes I'll hear it
on my own still tear up a little bit yet
for some reason the film doesn't really
sell it's really focusing would you get
Zac Effron ins and daya instead yeah
yeah a bit of an odd duck movie but hey
I left feeling joyous and you know that
the dancing Hugh Jackman looks nothing
like PT Barnum I did not know about this
whole monkey fishtail thing oh yeah very
disturbing oh yeah I've seen a few
feejee mermaids in person and they are
quite a thing to behold I don't know if
he's responsible for creating that thing
but I if he made one Hey and Jenny Lind
and PT Barnum did not have that kind of
relationship at all apparently I'm not
surprised
altogether by that like I didn't sit
there through the movie going this is
fabricated but I can definitely see how
it would be a movie like they had a
whole thing where she kisses him in
front of the crowd yeah it's like so
off-base with historical accuracy I love
that that either all-or-nothing approach
where it's like either okay that's an
event that would be highly publicized or
that's just not true it movie doesn't
care and in this case it's the latter
screen junkies this was a really funny
video appreciate you guys
putting in your hard-working doing this
to get some parodies - hey patron the
day shout-out format beer not beer mat
beer who is arguably the greatest
showman ever if you've ever met this guy
so gregarious so outlandish and knows
how to socialize like nobodies who's
this man this guy is the best
communicator the best hype man you'll
ever meet he works at a movie theater
currently and when you walk into that
movie theater he can sell you on why are
you gonna have a great experience when
you go there you know you might not even
buy a ticket you might just stay there
and watch Matt beard do his thing it's
the shots how much of a showman he is
this is me more like this is beer
transition into the outro okay guys you
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Bell so subscribe
buttons mean something and we'll catch
you on the flippety-flip atif Liberty
flip that's true
you